[Musik]
schau dass du die Kugeln gleichmäßig
aufhängstell nicht so Schir wie im
letzten Jahr die Tante anni die hat J so
ein schöner B und der unsere der schaut
aus wie kut und
rüutst zu ganz spzel oder Knödel machen
wenn du knödelst dann musst du die
machenaritmer SPZ machen aber kndel
genau wie be meinem Geschenk du ich hab
gesagt was wüns und ich hab gesagt du
musst GLE Ken sie das es ist Weihnachten
aber es kehrt überhaupt keine Ruhe ein
das muss nicht sein denn dafür gibt es
jetzt Oro Christmas frohe Weihnachten
mit Oro Christmas damit die stadeezeit
auch Start
bleibt dann dann habe ich nichts zum oze
wen am ziten
weihnachtsfeiertag